as we gear up to watch the likes of
Simone biles and Heather Morris shake it
on season 24 of Dancing with the Stars
we thought we would take a trip down
ballroom and memory lane these are six
of the most memorable moments last
season Ryan Lochte is dancing debut was
crashed by protesters honestly it felt
like someone just reached inside took my
heart out and just tore it to shreds
later that season a potential feud was
a-brewin between Amber Rose and Julianne
Hough though they quickly made peace
when you said that I felt very
embarrassed and I felt like you weren't
talking about my dance but if I
misunderstood then I apologize as a
judge on the show I'm here to solely
judge you and everyone else in this
competition for only the dancing so I
want you to know that but that same
season also brought us the ultimate
happily-ever-after
pro dancer Sasha Farber proposed to Emma
Slater
[Applause]
one must have at your wedding it sounds
really bad if I say vodka another happy
announcement on the show and make Carter
during season 22 we are going to reveal
the sex of your baby and you don't know
right so you're both going to learn
right here live
[Applause]
but who can forget less dramatic moments
with Marie Osmond in season five and of
course you've gotta show the Gaiety and
the fun of the samba
yikes and in season seven Kim Kardashian
shared of this revelation that had some
surprised the biggest challenge with the
Mambo is just shaking my butt everyone
thinks they know how and I just really
don't anything I need like booty 101
perhaps more surprising she was the
third contestant sent packing
[Music]